[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Give me
one minute, and I'll
show you how Chronicle
can detect security
exploits in your enterprise.
Let's say your
colleague Alex reports
encountering a suspicious
domain that asked
for her corporate credentials.
Chronicle allows you to quickly
search your security telemetry
for the suspicious domain.
You can also find out if
other employees or assets
have been compromised.
By stitching correlated data
points into coherent events,
Chronicle makes sense
of the massive data
to find vulnerabilities
like phishing, malware,
and more sophisticated
patterns of attack.
Even if the phishing attack
was unnoticed by Alex,
Chronicle may have alerted
you about the exploit.
Chronicle Detect integrates
with Google's own threat
intelligence, as
well as third-party
feeds, to identify
well-known exploits.
You can also migrate your
existing security rules
from existing tools
to Chronicle's
expressive language.
To use Chronicle, simply enable
Chronicle for your GCP project
in the console with
your one-time password.
Once enabled, Chronicle starts
to ingest your security logs
at scale.
So next time you look into
the tech vulnerabilities
across your fleet, take a
minute to explore Chronicle.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/chronicle.